good morning everyone welcome to another
episode of alexa and friends
my name is jeff blankenberg and if you
haven't been here before we spend our
time
talking with people from all across the
voice industry
uh and today i have the good honor of
talking with yoel mark who's the vp
of science and research at amazon
shopping so
well thank you so much for being here
thank you jeff shanks very thank you for
having me
certainly so one of the things that i
like to do early on in these interviews
is have a quick conversation with you
using some silly questions and i'm going
to ask you two of them
the first one um with all the new movies
we've had out about superheroes
i'm always interested to know what if
you could pick any one superpower for
yourself
of all the superpowers that you've ever
heard of which one would you
uh i would have preferred you asking me
you know who's my favorite uh superhero
that's an easier one because of course
of course i would have said you know
wonder woman
it makes sense right lots of powers
though so i need you to pick just one
the most extraordinary superpower
i'm thinking oh that's okay thinking is
good
maybe maybe empathy you know what the
the impact right the people that really
can
feel and understand what other people
really really feel so you know maybe not
too much like you know the marvel movie
because it can really get
bad right but just beginning a little
bit of that path so that you really feel
the other people
nice i like that uh i i think that the
whole world could use more of that for
sure
um but i i think that's uh that's a
lovely superpower all right
uh my second question and this one
requires a little storytelling
um revolves around a decision that
you're gonna have to make so i want you
to imagine for a moment that you're in a
big metropolitan city
and you're walking down the street and
you realize uh that the place that you
want to go is one street over
and so your options are to walk all the
way down and around the long city block
uh or there's an alley nearby and it's a
brightly lit day there's
it doesn't look dangerous there's
nothing to be scared of so you decide to
walk down
the alley to cut cut across to the place
that you're meeting some friends
uh and as you get about halfway down
this alley uh at the other end the end
that you're heading towards emerges a
giant
horse-sized duck so i want you to
imagine a very
very large duck okay uh now
it looks a little menacing a little mean
maybe and it doesn't look like something
that you really want to mess with so you
turn around
as you naturally wouldn't say i'm not
going that way anymore so you head back
the way you came
only to find that that end has been
filled with 100
duck-sized horses so very very small
horses
so my question for you is you're now
kind of trapped in this alley between
these two choices
if you have to fight your way out of
this alley which way would you choose to
go
i cannot guess where you're going with
this one but let me just go with my gut
feeling
that's perfect so i would i would keep
up with the horses
because first i would be more
comfortable trying to slalom between
small horses than you know i'm short so
i don't want to
to be in front of a duck because it's
even bigger for me yes
and and i prefer horses to duck to ducks
just in general this this interior i
don't know especially if they are small
very good okay so i like the words you
use too you're gonna slalom between the
ducks that's a very good word
uh in in the united states slalom often
means
uh like skiing style slalom
but i think that's a perfect word for
illustrating what you're trying to do
there
so i i like that very much all right so
now what i want to know
is i really wanted to get quickly to
what
um what i think we're all here for which
is to hear about you and hear about your
background
so what i ask people to do is kind of
share with me
your quick five-minute synopsis of your
history um
you have a very interesting role you're
working on a lot of very interesting
projects and we'll get to all of that
stuff
but i'm always interested to share with
people kind of where you came from where
did
where did you go to college what did you
study what kind of roles did did you
take to get to where you are today i'd
love to be able to share that whole
story
sure it's pleasure um but i'm dying to
understand the end of the story with the
duck of horses you know what does it say
about me about my personality
maybe we do that offline i'm curious
okay that's
very good um so speaking about me so
you hear me i have a french accent i
grew up in france
uh and then i went to do a my phd um in
israel at the technion at the time um
and
i did it you know in computer science
and during
a part of my phd uh just to be with my
then boyfriend would become my husband i
went to columbia university in new york
and i discovered the field of search of
information retrieval which is the
actually
the computer this science discipline
behind search but i'm talking 30 years
ago
and at that time nobody cared about it
absolutely you know it's pre-web era
i'm really a such dinosaur right and i
was you know
extremely lucky because you know trust
me nobody cared about it but i got you
know super excited about it it was a
little bit uh
a lot before time so i did my phd you
know in information retrieval
after finishing my phd i went to ibm
research
and i continued working in search but
you know at the time at ibm research it
was a database company so you would say
i don't want to do sql i want to do
free text search i don't want users to
start
learning boolean i want them to speak
naturally and it was weird and nobody
again nobody cared about it
so but you know i'm persistent when i
love something i'm persistent
i was just passionate about it um so i
continued you know working on that
uh joining the community at the time it
was a small community
and you know and the web arrived and i
was extremely lucky because then
suddenly people started to realize
oh search is not just for lawyers and
for
you know and or for physicians looking
for specific cases here and there
it's really we don't need to speak
boolean we can be natural it's for
everyone it's really the democratization
of search
and then suddenly everything i was doing
i didn't need to convince and convince
people who would understand it naturally
so at ibm at the time we you know i
drove i was part of the team that drove
the enterprise search
and because i published you know i kept
publishing because i love publishing
papers about my
my work um i got you know people at
google that
that knew my community just approached
me
so i left ibm research after 17 years
long long career and i moved to google
did very very cool things here uh pure
engineering you know
going from research to engineering and i
love the engineering side
impacting users you know my team is
credited for launching google suggest
which is the query completion
feature you all know it you start typing
and that's it you know magic uh
you know the engine completes what you
want to to write
and then i move to yahoo research where
many people don't know that
but yahoo actually did have this query
completion
launched it before google so i was i
really loved you know the way i
would treat users and also i wanted to
go back to publishing that was really my
big motivator because
engineering was cool impacting hundreds
of millions of years is awesome
i love to have impact but i want to talk
about it i talk too much right i'm
passionate about search
so i want to talk about about um about
that and that yeah
i had that i had this combination of of
you know of
of inventing for users but as well as
publishing
um and i worked you know i had the
privilege to work with marissa meyer
was actually with women i was working at
at yahoo and then she became the the ceo
of
um sorry i was working with her at
google and then she became the they
became the ceo
of of yahoo and working for a woman ceo
is really really cool
especially someone as cool as she was
and then you know i
i had the chance to be able to lead all
of your research to guide it before
before the acquisition and then you know
yeah was acquired so
i was still in search i was doing
enterprises then web search
and then at the end i was doing mail
search which was really really
interesting
and then at that point you know
acquisition i was just you know at
cornerstone and i was approached with by
amazon
and for me that wasn't something super
interesting because
because i was you know for me amazon was
products but they were not and very cool
products
very you know great impact on on
customers
but not very famous you know in research
and i wanted to keep this
double kind of agenda of yes you know
impacting users but also contributing to
the ecosystem and validating our
research
with the community and it so happened
that i was convinced by
at the time jeff wilkie would told me
yeah but now it's happening
and it's true that you know when i
joined amazon a little bit more than
three and
five years ago basically i see i see a
big revolution where and now you know we
have aws we have alexa
and we have even in our regular business
line there we have so many brilliant
scientists
that now was really the time to to make
amazon a world-class you know um
science company um and i jumped because
it was a next challenge
uh i did you know enterprise web mail
search i know it's
product search voice search and it's
really the next level
which is extremely more complicated and
and i love a good challenge right from
time to time
yeah i i think i think that's something
that people forget sometimes
is that work should be a challenge uh i
think a lot of people look for a role
that they feel
very comfortable and uh almost relaxed
in uh and i find
uh with voice especially i i didn't come
from a voice background at all
but i've been a software developer for
20 years or so and getting into voice
and learning this stuff
there's always that feeling of
discomfort like i i don't know
everything and i never will know
everything
um but having an opportunity to be
challenged every day and learn
and absorb um is it's my favorite part
of the job for sure and i i think
the more you can find a job that you
enjoy being challenged at uh the more
you'll enjoy your work so that's
fantastic to hear
yeah it's it's really been challenged
and you know i'm
a little bit older than you jeff and and
the fact that i
i'm being challenged and i keep learning
you know at amazon we love saying
learning and being curious but
if i was to go to another company maybe
you know they would use my expertise but
others that many companies where i i'm
challenged and i learn
every day every day and it's for my it's
not only you know for my
my peers or my my leaders it's also from
these young kids that are fresh out of
college
and that's that keeps you on your toes
that that keeps me excited
right no i'm i'm completely with you so
so that leads us to today so
you you've been in amazon you said a few
years now did you say three or five
years i missed your your words
three and a half years all right um so
tell me about your role today tell me
about what you're doing
sure so today i i serve as a vp of
science and research for alexa shopping
and our vision really for you know for
alexa shopping is is to read for for
for alexa to to become what we call the
go-to shopping companion
we want really to escort customers
in every aspect of their shopping
journey and and i insist on that you
know when i say on every aspect because
when people say oh shopping is all going
to be about you know it's only about
buying stuff no it's way more than that
yeah it's um
it's really it's not buying because it's
it's a journey
you you think about it you ask questions
about it you search about it
uh it's you know before you buy after
you buy
um and and the way that we are looking
at that is that you know we we really
have
tons of needs um what is interesting
actually it goes back to
at amazon we love to do things customer
backward right we start from the
customers
and if you look at customers they we
want to understand their needs
we want to we want really sorry about
that we want to understand their needs
we want to satisfy their needs
we want to delight people it's not only
just doing what they ask us to do we
want to
to delight and surprise them surprise
them and we won't even
when if i dream right to predict their
needs we want to try to suggest things
to them even before they think of it
so if we look at all that it's it's
really a way to uh
to um to innovate and it's
for me i'm looking at that as a natural
evolution of my career in search
yeah no i i think i completely agree
with that i think most of the people
watching
uh would probably agree the idea that i
could have
an engine and again this isn't for big
purchases this isn't like a special
um pair of jeans i'm gonna buy or
anything like that but there are so many
times in my life where
we're on our way to being out of a
staple in our house right paper towels
or batteries or something like that
um and i i wish i wish there was a
service that would remind me
hey by the way you're running low on
this or not even that just
hey by the way i've sent you some more
because i know you need this it's
happening
jack it's happening actually my team is
enjoying that and uh
it's probably going to happen to you
soon that you're going to have some
notification telling you you know you're
running out of toilet paper wait for it
and and i do see i do see hints of that
uh in the things that i see on alexa
right there will be times where it
reminds me
just on the screen like hey you're
you're probably almost out of this
uh assumption based on how off i order
right it's using a lot of pattern
matching to do with that
um but that that kind of stuff i think
makes a big big difference i
uh i spend a lot of time talking about
the idea that we can be using
our personal ai and machine learning
like alexa
to offload a lot of the day-to-day stuff
that
gets in our way of doing really awesome
stuff um and i really really like
the idea that um i could have ai
thinking for me behind the scenes and
worrying about
when i need paper towels and when i you
know all of that stuff
kind of falls into the background and
now i can focus on the things that are
important to me not
not buying paper towels you know that's
true and so if you
next time you have a notification
reminding you of something like that
remember it comes you know from one of
our scientists team
and they you know they run like very
smart you know ml
you know machine learning deep learning
models to predict it for you
and and we have to be super careful
because
if we predict and we are right it's
awesome but if we
we're wrong there is nothing more
annoying than that that's why it's so
difficult right
we need like a it's not like search like
if i if i look at search if i was
you know i was working on web search you
know mine 10 blue links that i showed to
you you know
six are good seven are good and three
are not so good big deal
but now if i give you one notification
and it's wrong this is really annoying i
really need hundred percent precision
and that's why you know i'm saying that
alexa is really the next level in search
because we have one chance to make you
you know
happy to satisfy you otherwise you're
disappointed and you won't come back
no i think that's very fair um all right
so we got a really good feel for your
background you've been a number of
places you said ibm and google and yahoo
uh now amazon um but i know you're also
working on uh something related to the
alexa prize right task assistance can
you tell me
a little bit about that sure so you know
when i the first time i
i heard about alexa price i found that's
incredibly
exciting because if you think of it
right we have
typically you have industry and you have
academia and maybe you have interns
coming here and there
but there are very few opportunities for
academia and industry to work together
and i do publish you know and i do
collaborate from time to time with with
uh
with faculty members but every time you
go to a conference you will hear
you know okay you know professors and
students saying oh we wish we had
the data and the pain points because you
know we know in industry the pain points
best
because we we work on toy systems on our
theory and
and if i want to work in ai or machine
learning i need the data
i need the you know access to people and
now comes a big surprise in one of the
most advanced you know ai platform
and suddenly you we have a way to
let academic collaborators
not only access or platform and play
with tools that
they need to take them you know years
for them to develop
but also to advance the state of the art
together with us
and access our customers and and willing
customers customers who are ready to
play right
ready to experiment how many times can
you tell you know an academic team you
know what
come come play with our bots and you can
you can access
hundred thousand million customer real
ones and
when you tell them then they just whom
they dream right it's it's like a
um you know it's a dream come true so
we had a social bot you know that many
of you are familiar with that so it was
a like surprise for a number of years
where it was awesome basically we i
don't know if you ever
you know probably you tried to tell
alexa you know let's chat
and then that's it you're having a
conversation you know i'm playing the
customer
and it's a fun and engaging conversation
and it's really you know
the we needed academia for that because
really multi-term conversation of that
sort
that can you know that can really last
i don't know two three four five ten
minutes is really up on research it's
super difficult to
to have a you know engaging conversation
like that
yeah and now we we took it to the next
level so you know i talked to my
colleagues at uh you know in alexa i
think i ai team the guys who
invented the price and who have the
infrastructure and we started to
brainstorm said you know what would be
the next challenge what type of other
challenge could we have
and and coming from search one of the
the the dream we always have when you
look at search
you can search for because you you want
to to
you know we call that informational
needs you because you want to discover
something you want to get more
information you can search because you
have transactional needs because you
want to buy something for instance and
it
happen in the web right not only for for
amazon
but you also want to search because you
want to go
further than info you know getting
information you want to do something
and we call that task assistance and and
when you
you need to do something it's actually
it's starting to be a very complex sound
of the need
it's not a one-time thing right you're
not asking for the weather of the
capital of alabama
you want to bake a cake without gluten
for 30 people
um i don't know with this type of
allergy this is complicated you want to
renovate your debt you want to refurbish
your oak table this is complex this is
not one session
so that's the idea we started to have we
said okay let's take now alexa
let's take the alexa price and now we
are not going to engage in a
fun and engaging and social conversation
we are going to try to engage in a
conversation
to solve a problem to really
assist a user a customer in a task that
they have to do
over time and for that you need to put
all the
you know the brightest mind because it's
incredibly complicated
yeah uh i my brain there stopped for
just a minute you mentioned making a
cake
uh i've been on a diet for the last six
months and now all i can think about is
how much i want some cake uh
that's amazing but no i i really
appreciate um
the the way that you guys are thinking
about this and the way that we're really
bringing academia into trying to solve
some of these incredibly hard problems
uh i think this is
this is a really exciting time and as
you were talking about shopping
obviously that's kind of core to
everything that you do here at amazon
these days
um let's let's backtrack a little bit
and talk about
information retrieval and web search and
some of the stuff that that you've had a
history in
um how do those the science and and
research around those topics
how does that help amazon shopping
oh everywhere so you know
uh so so so if you think of it
when um if we go back to the the no you
know natural journey of a user
when they they want to shop they
they're always going to try to to
discover stuff and so they are going to
to
ask you know either simple or complex
questions
and and that's really you know the
essence of search
but when you look at question answering
for instance it's going to be
um so search typically is when you enter
a request you know give me information
about that
what's the price of this so there is a
slight difference
such is why the question answering is a
is a subset of it
and and the we need to use the very
uh the latest method in in
information interval in machine learning
to get it right because what i was
saying before
if you're in now if you want you compare
um
shopping via alexa which is this type of
ambient search
to web search you have actually so few
shots you know to to to satisfy the user
that you need to actually
that's kind of the holy grail or what
google used to have i'm feeling lucky
right
one click because typically it's going
to be the first the first candidate that
needs to be the right one
so this stuff these are the type of
challenges that we we are tackling
and what we discovered actually that
when people
what makes it even more complicated is
then
when people uh search by voice their
behavior is slightly different than by
web
they are going to be uh maybe uh less
verbals or more verbs it depends it's a
new paradigm
people are learning to to to talk to a
machine and
when i say search now you know the the
the sense is actually the boundaries
between the different
disciplines of ai are now very fuzzy
when you see search it has
not only ml and deep learning but also
nlp
and also uh you know we are trying to
understand emotions so it's computer
computer human interaction so it's all
of it together
and um and funny enough that was at the
time you know when i uh
30 years ago when i discovered the field
of information retrieval
the reason for which i got excited about
it as opposed to other fields
is that he had so many layers of
different computer science discipline
it has system it had data structure it
had you know performance
and he had humans and and that's the
same thing here if you want to be
today a good scientist you need to be
very versatile like a renaissance person
going over many many disciplines so you
know so
i'm giving you a fuzzy answer because
it's it's all about everything
one key principle however in everything
we're doing
it's not as if we're taking a portfolio
of research and you know a
technology that is ready or that we're
inventing that we
dump on users on customers we are really
really using what we call
customer obsessed science so we start
from the customer
what they need or what we're predicting
they need if they paint or we want to
surprise them or to please them
and then backward we invent technology
or even with tech technology that exists
okay so we are going to use search if
that's what they need
but if they need something else we will
use something else and if we need to
invest something new we will invest
something new
i like the invention that's nice but
you're you're very right and i think
that's something that gets missed
sometimes is that amazon
is so incredibly focused on our
customers that we want to make sure that
we're doing what's right
uh for them and it's not just applying
the same technology a number of
different ways we're really looking at
in this specific instance this customer
is trying to do x y or z
how's the best way to solve that problem
for them uh and i think
i think that's fantastic um all right so
we we've we've dived a little deep on on
the search and the web search and
um a little bit of how that like you
said it's a it's fuzzy but it's a very
big gray ball
that is all of this technology um one of
the other problems that i know you've
talked about before
is computational humor and i'd love to
get into this just a little bit
because the idea of a computer trying to
be humorous or funny
is is uh is really really interesting to
me um as somebody that
tries to take technology and spin it in
a way that's accessible to
not only our customers but just humans
in general you have to add a flare for
humor and engagement sometimes um
so it sounds like it's a really hard ai
challenge though can you can you tell me
about it
sure so you remember i mentioned before
that we
we first need to understand customers so
again we are going to use here customer
backward approach
we don't want to be alexa to be funny
for the sake of it
right it so happened that we discovered
that our customers are funny
and if they are funny and they're joking
with alexa and so you can say today like
in customers reviews
if you go to amazon.com and you do you
need to be done in the reviews from time
to time you're going
you're going to get a good laugh just um
and and we stumbled upon it right we
were
working on question answering for from
customer reviews
and so you know we failed on reviews
that just made us you know crack it was
so funny
that's you an example right um
you know some products for instance are
intrinsically funny so there is this
type of banana slicer it's kind of a
plastic yellow mold with all kind of
plate
legendary i know all about it and so you
put it on a banana and shook you know in
one in one shot you slice it in many
many slices
and okay that's of course it's a joke
because you could do that with a knife
but you know maybe it's a little bit
useful or faster and one of the reviews
was uh
it was a question actually not a review
we're saying does this you know
plastic handler or plastic shape um
work if you're left-handed okay very
funny
but another one which much funeral said
what if my bananas
are banded the other way that's cool
right that's really cool
but that's true but so that way so we
discovered that today wow this is cool
but we have to be careful because
we have to understand that the customers
are joking
that what we they they are what we call
that you know being playful
because imagine that we use this type of
content
to answer a serious question elsewhere
right that would be really bad so that's
how it started right
it started from the real need and then
it started to evolve a little bit
because
we saw first that there were funny
comments
for funny products but we also have
funny comments
for absolutely regular products because
people are fun
and so we they're just fun right you
know when the first
echo show appeared you know some of the
reviews said will you show me my future
that's just that's funny that's cute and
the product itself is not
you know you know per se funny so we
started to build methods to detect that
and we had a paper at the cgr conference
one of my favorite conferences where
published i think my first paper more
than 30 years ago
uh it's a search it's a search i mean
you really had you know
an excellent really uh you know uh
opportunity to share what we
do we were doing there and so we have a
paper explaining how we can detect you
know
uh funny customer question of any
customer reviews
but all that it's we starting with
detecting and and the reason
why for which we look at computational
humor is because because
our customers are funny our users are
funny and if we want alexa
to be smart and to build trust
we need to make sure that she
understands or you know it i say she of
course
that's my friend's side right i put uh
but anyway
that that alexa will really understand
when a customer is is being funny so
that
alexa can understand in the same tone
because there's nothing more and knowing
that
you know assuming you know you joke with
me i don't get it and i have some
seriously
we don't build trust so that's super
important for us and that's uh and for
me it's not just a
nice to have thing i think it's key
in showing customers showing users that
alexa really understand
them even when they're not serious yeah
no i i think that's interesting i think
that detecting that humor i mean that's
hard for humans sometimes
to even recognize that something was
said sarcastically or as a joke
versus a serious question um that's uh
that's very very interesting thank you
for sharing that
it's a hearty eye challenge actually if
you go back to alan turing very famous
paper in the 50s
about machine intelligence he actually
says specifically that you know having a
machine
having a sense of humor it's like you
know it's a it's a big big big challenge
actually put that about you know
together with having machine having
emotions or
enjoying i think strawberries and cream
so that i'm not going to work on
right having alexandrian strawberries
and cream
but giving the alexa's sense of humor
absolutely yeah no i love that
uh so speaking of conferences um i know
there was a scientific conference wsdm
2021 was just recently
probably pronounced wisdom right correct
yes uh yeah and so
um you're on the organizing committee
for that conference is that right
so you know i'm in the steering
committee which means like you know
i've been around as i told you for a
while so i do remember when the
the the uh the conference was kind of
invented and you know
a little bit more than a decade ago it's
a spin-off of the big web conference
and uh we we felt that we needed this
kind of of a community so we don't stand
for
wsdm web search and data mining
and it was when you know the search was
exploding um
so today you know i've been pc chair a
few a few times and today i'm in syrian
committee so i'm behind the scenes
and uh this year i was super happy to
see two people in my team
uh leanne louis natan and david carmel
who actually did for the conference to
happen
to to you know you need to beat for a
conference to organize it
so i didn't organize it it's much better
it's my team so it's like you know i'm
super proud because they
they bid for it they they won the bid
and we had a wonderful conference but
two weeks ago
unfortunately it was virtual that's the
way it is so my team was disappointed we
were
really dying to host everyone it was
supposed to be in jerusalem it would
have been you know
super you know touristy for the uh for
all the attendees
but you know even the circumstances it
did happen you know
everything was smooth um that was you
know
for me it's it's even better you know
when you're not
it's it's actually it's a little bit
like i don't want to send
sound patronizing with like a parents
when you see that it's not you anymore
it's the next generation and they do
better
nothing more satisfying than that so it
was a wonderful conference
and even better one of our very very
young scientists uh
a woman named nikita which is nikita
vedula who just joined
one of my teams in seattle she even have
a a
a runner-up she was a finalist for best
paper so seeing all these you know
new talents fresh fresh you know
scientist or a little bit more
experienced like
the one organizing it putting together
such a fit it's
it's great and having amazon there you
know you remember the beginning of
our discussion when i was saying that a
few years ago amazon was not at the
front stage of of science we were
it it has changed i i'm proud to say
that today you know
we have a wonderful reputation in the
scientific community
yeah i have to say that one of the
biggest benefits for me uh being on this
alexa team
has been the access that i've had to the
amazon science organization
uh being able to connect with folks like
you and a number of your colleagues
uh and be able to learn and just discuss
some of these topics
uh has just been eye-opening for me to
see the kind of work that amazon's doing
and the
the passion and the energy that they put
into solving incredibly hard problems
for customers is
it's just remarkable to me so uh i i
agree it's it's quite remarkable how
much
um work is being done in the science
arena
um at amazon and you know what's crazy
that
they are so fearless i do remember every
time you know i i interview a candidate
i tell them
you know we have tons of exciting
challenges but you know it's hard
because we are trying open research
stuff and
and we are going to fail so often
because it's incredibly
complicated it's not as if you know
there is a line of sight and we're going
to deliver and we know what we're doing
we're trying we are inventing as we go
and
and all this young generation said okay
no problem
wow you know that i lose sleep but they
don't
and and the wonder is that yes i make it
happen they're so fearless
um maybe because i'm old and i see the
risk of failure but they don't
they just jump in the water and they
swim yeah
i think sometimes that's they don't know
what they don't know yeah
you you have a rich history of like
that's going to be really hard good luck
to you
they don't know that yet they'll know
they'll know eventually
um and that's uh that's great i love
that useful enthusiasm i mean i'm
uh you mentioned that you're older than
me but it can't be by much and i have a
rich history in this industry as well
um and it's it's amazing to me when i
see people that come in new and they're
like
oh that'll be easy i'll just do this and
this i'm like all right
have fun with that uh
all right so uh so as part of as part of
all of your work i know you guys do a
lot of collaborations with academia
obviously that makes a lot of sense
between these conferences and other
events um but one of the things that
you're involved with is our scholars
program which hires and allows academics
to join
amazon kind of like in a flexible
capacity where they're they're still
working for a university but they come
and spend some time with us do some
industry research
um how has that been beneficial to
amazon how
what what makes that work working with
universities around the globe
so i think i think it's uh it's a
wonderful thing
you know as i told you and i've been
around and i've seen uh
this kind of brain drain in the past
where we have to be honest right
industry would take away the most
talented scientists or researchers in
academia
and then it was for the benefit of
industry but then you know where
the the new generation of phd students
that these faculty could have uh
nurtured and educated
just you know just disappeared and if
you think of that it's it's wrong
it's wrong for the ecosystem it's being
greedy you take someone
right now wonderful right now but maybe
i lost 20
future scientists who didn't have the
chance to learn with this
faculty so the fact that we have this
scholar program is actually a beautiful
kind of selfless model it's not totally
selfless but i think it's a
rather a win-win model where we give
you know we give an opportunity to
faculty members
come play with our data you know what i
mentioned before having the chance to
play with all data
with our real problems and collaborate
with us at the same time they don't
leave academia and they keep nurturing
and they're better when they continue
working part-time with academia
total win-win uh we have a wonderful
uh success story so i feel better i
don't feel guilty that i'm stealing away
you know
uh brands from academia on the contrary
i help them getting better
and i invest in the future so i sleep at
night
more than that um what i'm saying that
we give them such opportunities so
giving you an example i have this
wonderful scholar in my team his name
his name is eugene agustin he's from
emory university
actually one of the emory teams
won last i think this just this past
year
of the alexa price so eugene i've been
working with him
at other companies and i've been
collaborating with him he's a big name
in the search
community i was co-chair with him of one
of the wisdom conferences
and as soon as i joined you know amazon
said i'm i'm
i'm dying to give him this chance to
collaborate with us
so he is he came he he came and joined
us
as a scholar so part-time and this year
actually spent a little bit more time
because he was on a sabbatical
and he said you know what what about
having an alexa price
because he has been an alexa price uh
competitor
from the academic side and now that he
was on our side he actually
helped us build this task this new task
assistance channel so he's behind the
scene
it's wonderful right it's as if you're
an actor and suddenly you're you're uh
your producer or your you know your
director
and now he was really one of the key
brand you know with other
other scientists in my team like oleg
and others or like roklanko and others
and the and he basically helped us
design a
what i think is wonderful new challenge
which is alex surprise task assistant
and the fact and for him it was a dream
right he's
first he was just a participant he was
competing and now he can actually
give back to the entire community of
scientists he's the one really helping
build us he's the best person
to design because he's been on the other
side so that's an example of a great you
know scholar story
and i'm looking i'm looking at it really
again as a as a win-win
well and you set that up perfect for me
my next question is really to get
into the taskbar challenge and talk
about what that is and kind of help
people understand what problems you're
trying to solve so can you can you give
us the high level overview of the
taskbar challenge sure
so so i mentioned it before right we for
task assistance is really the
the most complex and next next
generation of search
and it has everything inside right it's
a it's melted on conversation it's over
device it's uh it's over time because
you start you don't you have to go and
get some ingredients if you're
we're caking i'm going to make you again
think about a chocolate cake
but you need to maybe you miss something
so it's over time so
you take all you need to get contacts
etc so this is a
difficult research problem now what the
competitors need to do so
we are we recruit uh we open the
challenge right now it's running uh yeah
we have the call open for applications
so academic teams and these are really
the students are going to
to be tasked with building what we call
a task board
like you know the previous alex surprise
was social but
now it's about a robot but for task
and they need to build this this um this
taskbar that's going to be able
to help customers address their tasks so
we say you know
alexa can you help me with baking uh
chocolate cake
and they need to build these birds that
are going to be able to converse with
users
asking the right questions suggesting
things we're also using
the um multi-modal devices where we're
going to ask them to show stuff it's not
only
speaking you know because you need
information which is visual as well
right and yeah we are going to select up
to
10 is that so that the regularizer price
model
these teams are going to apply and we
really hope to
to attract as many um you know different
diverse teams
from all over the world like for the
social world we will select
up to ten and these ten that will be
selected
we will make we will help them in any
way we know we give them
250k to pull the students together
and then we we give them access to data
to platform
and eventually if their bot qualifies
and
passes the bar of quality we put them
you know
you know really in the limelight we let
them play with actual actual users
and the best of them is going to be the
big winner and of course a
beautiful you know monetary price for
the students
for the students which is a kissing not
for the university for the students
that's lovely and it's it's a lot of
money right i think the top team gets
what five hundred thousand dollars yeah
yeah wow that's amazing um so
i think uh for anybody that's watching
or still thinking about this it's
probably
two if you haven't started on this
already it's probably too late but i
think you guys are taking applications
until the middle of the month middle of
april
yes correct and uh but you know
i think that uh even if
they should take you know they should
take some risk even they are not
such a big expert if they are really in
the in the field
they should give it a try maybe you know
they won't be qualified the first year
but they
they will learn while doing that and and
you know it's a it's a challenge that's
going to continue for three years
so start now build some experience and
maybe in three years you're going to to
to win it right
i like that encouragement so if for
those of you working in this stuff give
it a give it a shot you've got until
april 16th to get your application in
and then i think this is something that
we can kind of pay attention to and
engage over the summer right this is
when
a lot of their work will be done um the
competition starts in june is that
correct
i don't remember but i think it's on our
website
okay okay very very good um well i
i love the story about the the prize
money going to the students um i think
that's really exciting because i think a
lot of this stuff
is just assumed that that's going to go
back into the program or back to the
university in some way and
i like that the students can actually
make a little bit of money
as a prize that's that's fantastic um
all right so i only have a couple of
questions left for you but i think that
uh we still got a good
a good couple of stories to talk about
um i know that
we've talked about customer obsession
quite a bit already
how does something like this taskbot
challenge help us
think about customer obsession
um i think you know the the
if you think about what we're doing in a
in multitude conversations
so that so i'm going to be a little bit
uh you know just a little bit scientific
here i like it
so typically when you look at
conversations or conversation management
or dialogue management what was done in
the past was really for you know some
smart people and tried thinking you know
of
of um of an ideal dialogue manager think
of it over
like a graph or a workflow and they
would try to imagine
how a conversation would happen and you
know what
it doesn't work because users are not
predictable
and you can imagine try to imagine even
if you put the smartest people around
right
you can try to imagine all the possible
paths doesn't work like that
no no no so so if we're talking about
conversation
and customer obsession and working
customer background
it's really really one of the key um you
know of the key concept of the key
approaches of our of of amazon we do
everything customer backward
so now if we want to build a real you
know
revolutionary dialogue management or
conversation management
we simply need data we need to make it
for true conversations
from true people but now what's the
problem it's like a chicken and egg
problem
i want to build a good system for you
but you never it's a new one
it's called start right we never had
something like that so
how am i going to start am i going to
crouch saucia i can do
a little bit of crowd sourcing and to
try to simulate conversations
but what we really need to do is to
encourage people to take risks
um having bots uh like social about
lactase work less than play
it's not critical if it's you know if it
fails let them play and let them be
natural
and if we can assemble and gather
enough data then we are going to to to
generate better things because
you know what you know ml and there is
it's all about you know
starting from data but it's not starting
from data in the back end it's trying
for
starting from real data from brain users
so that's that's how we're looking at it
very very cool all right and so um as we
put a bow on this whole taskbar thing is
there um
can can anyone that's watching or that's
interested how can they engage with this
oh so it's it's uh everything is on
amazon science so go there
uh you can actually you know there are
many
ways to apply and if you google it
you're going to find it
but go to the amazon science site
amazon.com
go there and you'll see all the details
how to apply
perfect perfect perfect uh what about
those people that want to interact with
the bots
um i i imagine they can play on their
devices with this
absolutely so it's like today if today
you start
and you say you know tell alexa let's
let's chat
you will be actually uh you will start
immediately playing
with one of the university boats and
that's it start the conversation
so as soon as or you know it's going to
be towards the end of the year
when you know we need to select the
competitor for the tesla they're going
to develop it they're going to qualify
that many stages
so that's why i'm telling you you know
you need to be ready to compete you're
going to build it you need to convince
us that you're capable of building such
a thing and you have a little bit of
intuition and a little bit of
know-how in this film you can go and
jump because it will take you
you know maybe six to eight months to
build this thing
and then toward the end of the years of
the year these qualifying bots will be
exposed to real users and all of us will
be able to say
alexa can you help me with i don't
remember exactly the utterance we
maybe it's going to change but there
will be a key one that we will uh
our chance of you set my device off
that's nice work
and she understand my french accent you
know what it is that's that's really
special
very good um i i have to say i think i
think the phrase
is help me with a task i think that's
what yeah i've seen something like that
right
um all right this is this has been
fantastic you all
i really appreciate you being here today
i want to make sure that people know uh
where they can find you and some of your
research
and your team so like you mentioned
everybody can find everything on
amazon.science if you want to read any
of the research
that we've been talking about and she's
been leading with our teams i think
there's also a recent blog post about
the taskbot challenge
which i encourage everyone to read uh
and we'll i think we've probably already
shared the link in the in the chat but
if we have it i'll make sure that that's
included there as well
uh and like uh like we all mentioned you
can try uh
i won't say the name alexa but
you can say let's chat and you can talk
to a lot of the academic bots that are
out there today
um or you can say help me with a task to
try some of these more taskbar
focused bots so you all i want to thank
you so much for joining us today it's
been
it's been my pleasure getting to talk
with you is there anything else that
you'd like to share before we wrap up
today
um i think there was a question you know
i i'm sorry i couldn't really while
talking to jeff i really couldn't
follow all the comments but uh one
question then one of you guys uh
rose was about asking us you know what
attracts scientists to come to amazon so
i have to i have to answer this question
because um
because basically you know at the
beginning i didn't think of joining
amazon because
a few years ago it was really not the
place to to go and i know it's
definitely the place to go i would say
of course i
am biased but but what i'm going to tell
you is
scientists join us when they want this
kind of duality
you can you know you can if you want to
do fundamental science
academia is great right that's where you
should be because you want to advance
and educate
and i love it and we want to have more
you know stronger a strong academia for
our ecosystem
if you want to impact impact and launch
launch launch go to engineering that's
fine also i've been an engineer i loved
it
but if you want to do this combination
right you want to
innovate on behalf of users and and but
probably you know launch things not
alone right together with engineering
partners and publish about it
because you want to contribute to the
ecosystem so you want to
write papers you want to develop code
but to do two of them together
so if you're a little bit you know weird
and have two
you know not one passion but two
passions at the same time
we are the people we are really really
looking always for
people who are double money and we want
applied science not hundred percent in
here not from brisbane there
or maybe twice hundred percent it
doesn't make sense mathematically but
you get one point
no i think that's really good direction
uh and i find i find similar parallels
in my job too right
um i do a lot of engineering but i also
do a lot of research and customer
interaction and trying to understand
exactly what not only our developers
want but also what our end users want
how we fit all of those things together
it's uh
it's really exciting uh and i'm glad i
get to be a small part of it too
uh all right well you all thank you
again so much for being here today
uh it is been my pleasure and i hope
that our audience uh
got something interesting out of today
there was a lot of interesting points to
be taken away
uh the replay of this will be available
on youtube and twitch
uh not long after we're done here so
thank you guys all for tuning in we will
be uh we will be skipping next week
there's no episode here next week
i'm taking a little vacation and so
we're going to skip next week but we
will be back the following week
with another incredibly interesting
guest here talking about voice so thank
you guys all for watching alex and
friends
we will see you all very soon thank you
thanks